global economic growth has slowed and
the latest figures from china and u.s
are a bit disappointing
even the imf has predicted a heart year
2015 a difficult year 2015.
what that does that mean i will talk
about this with stefan schneider from
deutsche bank research
mr schneider
what did the dbx do in january
actually the dbx dropped by another 10th
percentage point from 0.4 in december to
0.3 and if we look at the driving forces
it's mainly the us where the ism has
dropped by one and a half
points which is one of the weakest for
the last 12 months
we saw also a small drop in the chinese
indicator whereas the indicators for
europe and japan actually continue to
improve
the falling oil prices are quite good
for the world economy of course
the oil producing countries have
problems with that oil price what kind
of long-term effects does the low oil
price have
i mean it's first of all a good for the
number for the countries we are looking
at i mean these are all
industrialized economies or
big oil importers so they should all
benefit from lower oil prices and some
rules of thumb show that uh decline of
the oil price by some 40 50 percent like
we have seen it to have seen it right
now should add roughly three quarters of
a percentage point of global gdp which
is obviously distributed unevenly the
oil exporters are suffering we can see
that in russia but also other countries
and it might in the medium term have
also an implication for for oil supply
that some of the supply will be taken
out of the market or not come on stream
which means that in the medium term
probably oil prices will recover
somewhat to two levels we have seen
maybe a in the middle of last year
at the moment the
low oil price and is a problem for the
european union inflation rate yes this
inflation rate and the aim to to um
of the
or the ecb is to have an inflation rate
of about two percent what is behind this
magic number of two percent actually
it's a problem people would like to have
because it means strong real income
gains oil prices are down nine percent
on the year this has driven the euro and
inflation rate into negative territory
the most recent reading was minus 0.6 so
i think overall we should not really be
too much worried about the job
we should actually enjoy it and we can
see that consumers are taking advantage
of it we can see that consumer spending
and consumer confidence is picking up
but the ecb is worried about long-term
inflation expectations and the concern
is that the consumers and investors will
basically start thinking that even in
the medium term inflation will be way
lower than the ecb's target which is
slightly
below two percent and that might have an
impact on their spending behavior and it
might also
cause some constraints for monetary
policy so the ecb would like to see
inflation expectations which have most
recently come down a little bit but
which are honestly not so much forward
looking
to to reconverge to around two percent
what we have seen in january was that
the swiss bank the swiss national bank
has abandoned the cap between euro and
the swiss franc what
what why did they
why have they decided about that i mean
the swiss national banks president
jordan made it explicitly clear he said
it was
aimed for a certain adjustment period to
give the swiss industry the expert
orientated industry time to adjust to
the strongest swiss rank and the other
argument of course was
the policy innovation in in europe
meaning that the ecb at the beginning of
january had decided to start a massive
qe program 60 billion per month adding
more than one trillion to the ecb's
balance sheet and of course um stemming
against this one would have caused the
ecb's this this national bank's balance
sheet almost to explode jordan just said
if the inflows
the snb saw just in the first few days
of january if that had continued the
balance sheet would have grown by 100 of
swiss gdp within the first six months
and of course that's then something
where a central bank has to think
whether that's a viable policy
well the um
ecb's bond purchasing program
you mentioned
lead to less confidence in the euro
i mean i wouldn't call it less
confidence but obviously the one of the
effects is that we'll probably see
outflows of the uracil out of the
eurozone because obviously the returns
of bond yields are so depressed and that
some maybe foreign investors taking
their money out of the eurozone maybe
some european investors who start
looking at treasuries or
uk guild will take their money out and
that will then cause the depreciation of
europe which we have already seen in
anticipation of the ecb's policy move
and
given that the other factors the other
transmission channels of the qe are
pretty limited in the eurozone i think
the ecb is hoping for the effect of a
weak exchange rate which will obviously
lift inflation in the medium term and
also should be beneficial for european
exporters
loss of confidence is not the only
problem for the european union at the
moment all eyes are on greece the new
greek government rejected the troika and
called for an end of austerity that's
what we will be talking about in our
focus interview you can watch this
interview on dw dot de slash english
slash made in germany